this is an iPhone it's sold by an
American company Apple made by Taiwanese
manufacturers and features components
made in places like Germany Japan and
South Korea since being released it's
become the most successful tech product
ever the iPhone is an incredible
globalization success story but did you
know it's secretly British that's right
in fact so are around 99 of the world's
smartphones how is that possible to
understand why we're going to need to
learn about one of the most fascinating
companies in the history of tech they're
a Semiconductor Company that's never
made a single chip let's Dive In
[Music]
1979 was a very eventful year in the
United Kingdom in January tens of
thousands of public sector workers
started to strike in what became known
as the winter of discontent in May
Margaret Thatcher became the nation's
first ever female leader and in October
a documentary started a revolution
the mighty micro is probably the most
influential TV program ever shown in the
UK at the time Computing in Britain was
basically just a niche activity for
nerds but across six episodes the
computer scientist Dr Christopher Evans
argued that microprocessors would
transform the whole of society he warned
that unless immediate action was taken
to educate the British public about
computers then the UK would be left
behind that warning immediately raised
an alarm inside a government already
struggling to prevent the country from
falling into recession the newly elected
Thatcher government knew it needed to
act the end result was the computer
literacy project an incredibly ambitious
BBC campaign to teach people everything
from how microprocessors worked to how
computers would impact education and
white collar work as part of this work
the BBC decided to commission a new home
computer which would serve as the
example model used to explain the
principles of computing everyone in the
British Computing industry knew that
winning the contract would basically
guarantee them millions of pounds it
quickly came down to just 2 companies
the first was Sinclair research Sinclair
research was headed by Clive Sinclair an
entrepreneur who'd previously run a
company which released the first
Slimline calculator the other candidate
was a company named Acorn started by an
engineer named Christopher curry curry
and Sinclair had history in fact they'd
previously been business partners the
companies Sinclair used to run before
Sinclair research had run into financial
problems and needed a bailout from the
UK government which resulted in them
basically taking the company over
Sinclair used that as an opportunity to
Pivot into home computers and he asked
Curry his most talented engineer to help
him do it in June of 1978 Sinclair
research then known as science of
Cambridge released its first product the
mk-14 the MK14 was really successful it
sold about 15 000 units which was a lot
at the time but the two men soon had a
falling out about the direction of the
company Curry wanted to continue the
development of the mk-14 while Sinclair
wanted to Branch out into other products
so Curry quit and together with an
Austrian researcher and entrepreneur
named German Hauser he soon started a
new company they call it Cambridge
processor unit CPU their first customer
was a business that made Fruit machines
a kind of slot machine that's popular in
the UK by January 1979 Curry and Hauser
were ready to release their first
product a microcomputer designed by a
Cambridge student named Sophie Wilson
and modeled on an automated cow feeder
but they were worried they knew that
they could build a decent business just
by doing things like making controllers
for fruit machines but releasing their
own product that was a way bigger risk
so they decided to launch a new product
under a different trading name to hedge
their risk they wanted something that
alluded to the amazing potential of the
computer industry with the added bonus
of appearing before Apple in the phone
book so they called the new division
Acorn computer and the new product the
acorn system one the sales of the system
one were good enough to convince Curry
that Acorn could grow into something
Mighty the system series eventually
evolved into the atom acorn's first
computer aimed squarely at the Home
Market but by then the company Chris
Curry had left since their research had
become the UK's leading computer
manufacturer they'd released the zx80 it
was massively popular and customers
often needed to wait months to get one
when Clive Sinclair heard about the
computer literacy project he wrote to
the BBC informing them that he'd soon be
releasing the follow-up to the zx80 the
new computer the zx81 would be cheaper
and more advanced plus he argued by the
time the BBC series aired more than a
hundred thousand people would be using
it so the choice came down to Sinclair's
zx81 or Acorn but Acorn weren't just
going to show the BBC the atom they'd
already been working on a successor at
the proton which would have better
performance there was just one problem
the proton only existed on paper the
acorn team was given just one week to
build a working prototype so they got to
work the project was led by Sophie
Wilson who by this stage had joined
Acorn as an employee after four days she
had a prototype but the software was
full of bugs so she had to stay up all
night trying to debug it she remembers
watching the wedding of Prince Charles
and Lady Diana Spencer on a small portal
portable TV while trying to debug and
re-solder the Prototype it was really
hard work but it would all be worth it
because the BBC ended up awarding the
contract to Acorn and although I'm sure
they didn't grasp it at the time they
just made a decision that would have
huge consequences not just for the UK
but for the entire world the proton was
rebadged as the BBC micro at first just
12 000 were made but it went on to sell
1.5 million units and become the most
influential computer in British history
at its peak there was a BBC micro in
almost every classroom in the UK it made
Chris Curry and Herman Hauser
Millionaires and acorn a success but
there was no time for complacency
because a new product had just arrived
that would change the game
you're looking at a small portable
computer called the IBM 5100 IBM's PC
transformed desktop Computing from a
niche hobby into a must-have business
tool part of the reason why was because
of its Superior performance which it
achieved thanks to a 16-bit Intel 88 V8
CPU 8-bit designs like the BBC micro
just couldn't compete the team at Acorn
saw the performance of the IBM PC and
other computers like the Apple Lisa
which popularized the concept of a
graphical user interface and decided to
develop a computer aimed at business
users they set themselves an ambitious
goal a 10x performance improvement from
the BBC micro but at the same price
Sophie Wilson and the rest of the
engineers began looking around for
available CPU designs most existing
16-bit designs only delivered marginal
performance improvements compared to the
micro they almost always needed a large
number of support ships to operate which
made them consume lots of power and
pushed up the price they asked the
leading American shipmaker for their
16-bit design but were turned down the
emerging 32-bit designs cost even more
acorns Engineers realized that nothing
currently on the market could meet their
needs it looked like they were stuck
until they read one of the papers which
acorn's co-founder Hermann Hauser left
on someone's desk in the paper two UC
Berkeley academics discussed the design
and implementation of a new kind of
processor the design was called the
reduced instruction set computer or risk
the two academics David Patterson and
Carlos sakin argued that you could
achieve most low level operations Faster
by delivering shorter more powerful
instructions and that might mean you
could build faster more efficient
processors during a visit to the Western
Design Center in Phoenix Arizona the
acorn team noticed that the chips were
being designed by sticking things to
drawing boards with sticky tape it made
them realize that if people could build
an effective microprocessor under those
resource constraints they could do it
too so they got to work Sophie Wilson
wrote a simulation of the processor
known as the instruction set in just 808
lines of code in a version of basic
designed specifically for the micro on a
per line basis that might be the most
valuable code ever written Acorn picked
a Silicon Valley based company called
vlsi technology to physically design and
fabricate the chip
first trip was delivered on April 26th
1985. after a couple of tweaks the
screen displayed the message hello world
I am arm
based on the risk design the arm1 used
fewer transistors less power and
generated less heat all while delivering
the superior performance that Acorn
craved the arm one worked great but
despite its amazing performance Acorn
was actually in big financial trouble
sounds crazy after all it had just won
the BBC micro contract but a combination
of supply chain problems missed sales
forecasts development costs and
misjudged expansion plans meant that in
February of 1985 one of acorn's
creditors issued a winding up petition
it turned out that Acorn actually owed
more than 31 million pounds it needed a
Lifeline thankfully it got one after a
short period of negotiations the Italian
I.T company olivetti bought a 49.3 stake
in acorn for 10.39 million pounds Acorn
had been valued at 216 million pounds
just the previous year the two Founders
Chris Curry and Herman Hauser saw their
combined ownership stake fall from 85.7
percent to just 36.5 percent a few
months later acorn's major creditors
agreed to write off almost 8 million
pounds in debts the BBC waived 50 of the
outstanding royalty payments and all of
Eddie increased its stake in the company
to almost 80 percent the second
refinancing further deluded Curry and
Hauser's combined ownership share to
less than 15 percent and basically
spelled the end of their major
involvement with Acorn had the company
they started gone out of business the
Apple we know today probably wouldn't
exist more about that later for now
Acorn had suffered but survived and
remember they still had one incredible
asset the arm one the company's new
leaders thought their processor deserved
new hardware so in 1987 Acorn released
the Archimedes the first risk-based
personal computer it shipped with the
arm one processor and the acorns
proprietary OS reviews all mentioned how
fast it was but disappointingly most
also mentioned the lack of software
support Acorn estimated they'd sell 20
000 Archimedes machines by the end of
1987 and 120 000 by the end of 1988 but
by the middle of 1988 they'd only sold
about 14 000. it was popular in the UK
but barely made a splash in bigger
markets like the US where people prefer
preferred computers like the Atari St or
the Amiga acorn's Flagship risk-based
personal computer was kind of a flop
just a few years after winning the most
important contract in British Computing
and then designing the most Innovative
microprocessor on the market Acorn
suddenly had a problem the Archimedes
which was their attempt to break into
the PC market was struggling and the
incredible advance that Sophie Wilson
had made with the arm one was in danger
of going to waste because of its
risk-based architecture and unique
instruction set the arm one provided
good performance while using less power
than almost anything else on the market
but it was tough to make that Advantage
count in the age of desktop Computing
Acorn needed to find a better use case
for the arm one they found one in
Silicon Valley but not from their
silicon partner vlsi technology instead
the answer came from Apple around the
time Acorn developed the arm one Apple
created an internal research lab the
purpose of this lab which they called
the Advanced Technology Group was to
research technologies that were outside
the scope of any individual product
group it was basically Google X but 25
years earlier Engineers of the Advanced
Technology Group loved the arm one
processor because of its elegant design
and low power consumption they thought
it would be perfect for the Apple II
line of personal computers so they got
in touch with the team at Acorn the
collaboration resulted in the creation
of an experimental prototype for a
risk-based personal computer to replace
the Apple II it was codenamed Mobius it
contained a modified arm processor and
it was incredible the Mobius performed
better than any of Apple's existing
processors you'd think that would be
great news right wrong the Mobius was
perceived as the threat by the existing
product groups after all how could Apple
release a competitor to the Macintosh
with a processor made by a direct
competitor it didn't really make any
sense so the Mobius project was quietly
shut down but that wasn't the end of
Apple's collaboration with Acorn shortly
after the Mobius Apple turned its
attention to another product Apple
started working on the Newton in 1987.
the processor had to meet stringent
benchmarks for performance power
consumption and cost all while running
on batteries there was only one
processor that came close to meeting all
of those requirements the arm one but it
still wasn't perfect so apple and acorn
agreed that they develop a modified
version of the arm processor which would
do everything the Newton needed after
the Mobius Fiasco though Apple was wary
they wanted to use Arm technology but
didn't want to base a product especially
one that they thought would be really
successful on a direct competitor's
intellectual property so Apple Acorn and
vlsi Technology came up with a solution
they created a new company which would
own the IP for the Newton's processor it
was structured as a joint venture Apple
invested 3 million and in return would
own part of the new company there's some
confusion about whether it was 30 or 43
but either way it was a big chunk the
LSI technology would provide the design
tools and Fabrication expertise and
Acorn would provide 12 of their
Engineers from the advanced research and
development group that had developed the
arm one processor in November of 1990
Advanced risk machines was born
this is where the acronym arm comes from
although today you won't find the words
Advanced risk machines anywhere on their
website acorn's story would continue
until late 2015 but arm's story had just
begun Robin Saxby an engineer with
experience in the semiconductor industry
was appointed as the inaugural CEO and
in 1993 the Newton launched complete
with an arm 610 microprocessor it was
Apple's first handheld device with
features like a touch screen and email
it was a precursor to the iPad and
iPhone but it totally failed it was
expensive and its handwriting
recognition was so bad The Simpsons made
fun of it
remember when you're Newton beat up
Martin
maybe people just weren't ready but
despite being a massive failure the
Newton would actually end up being great
news for both companies let me explain
starting with arm even though the Newton
had failed to kick off the mobile
Revolution arm's new CEO didn't want to
Pivot to the PC market for one thing
companies like IBM Sun Microsystems and
Hewlett-Packard had already cornered the
market for microprocessors that powered
desktop computers and more importantly
the alliance between Microsoft and Intel
known as Wintel meant you couldn't run
Windows and computers with armed chips
basically it was Intel or nothing an arm
was too small to break in but maybe
small was the way to go just because the
Newton failed didn't mean all handheld
devices would the other thing the
failure of the Newton did was teach
Robin Saxby arm's new CEO that they
couldn't pin their hopes on the success
of a single product one more failure
would probably mean the end of arm so he
devised an unusual business model arm
would stick to its role of just
designing microprocessors and it would
license the use of its microprocessor
users or more specifically the
instructions set first written by Sophie
Wilson to other companies this achieved
two things at once firstly it would make
arm a partner to every company that
licensed its designs which meant that
arm architecture would be used in a
larger ecosystem and secondly it would
generate a dual Revenue stream for arm
The Upfront licensing fees plus ongoing
royalties for every device that's
shipped with an armed product inside at
the time not many people thought the arm
business model would make a big
difference in the early 1990s the
desktop computer was still King and
Wintel was building a monopoly in that
exact sector but the times were changing
and fast and arm was about to hit a big
turning point in 1993 Texas Instruments
which was one of the world's biggest
semiconductor companies was approached
by Nokia to develop a processor for a
new mobile phone Texas Instruments which
was already using arm architecture
suggested a design based on the new arm7
microprocessor but Nokia couldn't see a
way to make that design small enough or
cost competitive so they said know in
response arm worked with Texas
Instruments to tweak the instruction set
the result was the arm7t a processor
that was still 32-bit but could process
16-bit input on the fly through
dedicated circuits inside the chip Nokia
loved the new processor and put it
inside the new 6110 the 6110 was a big
step forward for mobile phones thanks to
the arm7t it was the first phone to ship
with features that would become standard
like menu icons and the game Snake it
went on to be a massive success Nokia
sold 41 million cell phones in 1998 and
eclipsed Motorola to become the biggest
mobile phone manufacturer in the world
the 1990s mobile revolution had arrived
and it was great news for arm suddenly
their processors were inside one of the
hottest consumer products in the world
remember the biggest strength of the arm
instruction set was that it was energy
efficient an arms business model
introduced by its CEO Robin Saxby and
formalized by the company's work with
Texas Instruments meant that Partners
could modify the design to best suit
their needs the armed 7 family went on
to become the world's most widely used
32-bit embedded processor family with
more than 170 silicon licensees and over
10 billion units shipped since its
introduction in 1994. these weren't just
used in Mobile phones the PlayStation 2
Nintendo DS and even the Roomba used
processors from the rm7 family the 1990s
were very good for arm on April 17 1998
the company listed on the NASDAQ in less
than 13 years arm had turned 808 lines
of basic code written by Sophie Wilson
into a billion dollars everything was
looking great but over in Cupertino
things were looking bleak
Happy New Year everybody
here we go by the mid 90s Apple was in
deep trouble the company's leaders
didn't have a clear idea of how to
respond to the PC threat an alliance
with IBM and Motorola resulted in a new
risk-based instruction set architecture
power PC which performed well but
undermined Apple's point of difference
new versions of the Macintosh like the
Quadra Centris and performa Confused
customers and attempts at game-changing
new products like the Newton mostly
failed how bad was it well three
different CEOs in a four-year span
presided over 1.7 billion dollars in
losses IBM tried to buy Apple for 40 a
share in 1993. apple said no but then
tried to get IBM interested again after
their stock price fell way below that at
one point Apple was hours away from
being acquired by Sun Microsystems
things looked really bad and people
forget this about Apple but Apple had
something stashed away for a rainy day
their Equity stake in arm the company
began slowly selling off their Holdings
they used part of the proceeds to buy
next software for cash and stock in 1996
buying next did two things for Apple it
gave them control of technology that
they wanted to use as the foundation for
Mac OS 10 and it brought Steve Jobs back
to the company in an advisory role of
course jobs wouldn't remain a bystander
for very long by July of 1987 he was the
interim CEO following the resignation of
Gil Emilio the next month he appeared
together with Bill Gates at the Mac
World Expo to announce a historic
agreement Microsoft promised to support
office for the Mac for the next five
years while Apple agreed to make
Internet Explorer the default browser
for the Mac Gates also promised to
invest 150 million dollars for shares of
Apple's non-voting preferred stock
people were skeptical the deal basically
handed Microsoft a monopoly on operating
systems but jobs didn't exactly have
much leverage Apple was reportedly just
90 days away from bankruptcy jobs also
moved quickly to cancel money losing
projects like the Newton at the same
time he was cutting costs he also
continued selling off Apple stake in arm
by February of 1999 Apple had sold off
1.1 billion dollars of armed stock it
was a pretty great return considering
that they only invested 3 million
dollars initially and it helped Apple
stay in business jobs introduced
successful new products like the iMac
and iPod but in the early 2000s he
started noticing something lots of
people were carrying around mobile
phones MP3 players and blackberries
wouldn't they just be happier with a
single device that performed all of
those functions jobs also realized that
as mobile phones got better they'd start
challenging the dominant Market position
of the iPod jobs knew where those Trends
were pointing so he asked his head
Hardware software and design Engineers
to start work on a highly confidential
project to design a new Apple phone and
we are calling it
iPhone
the first generation iPhone was packed
with new technology like small
Lithium-ion batteries touch screens and
Gorilla Glass but in order to make
everything work together it needed a
powerful energy efficient CPU there
seemed like an obvious choice Intel it
could both manufacture and help design
the chip plus it had already been
working closely with Apple for years but
then something interesting happened
Intel's then CEO Paul ottolini said no
the company was making billions of
dollars from its duopoly with Microsoft
built on the foundation of the mighty
x86 architecture and the iPhone was the
first product of its type there was no
guarantee it would be successful the
numbers just didn't work out on the
spreadsheet I should note there's some
disagreement about how exactly this
played out in his biography Steve Jobs
said Apple turned Intel down because
they were too slow and because Apple
didn't want to strengthen a direct
competitor but however it happened
Intel's failure here opened the door for
arm arm had already supplied the CPU for
for the iPod which by 2007 was
generating almost half of Apple's total
revenues and of course it helped Apple
avoid bankruptcy in the 90s that's how
the very first iPhone ended up
containing a Samsung built arm system on
a chip every single one of the 2.3
billion iPhones sold since then has
included an arm core of some kind it's
one of the most successful and lucrative
collaborations in business history and
it's the reason your iPhone is secretly
British so is every iOS device and 99 of
the world's smartphones even your Kindle
Fitbit and DJI drone are British the
reason why is that business model Robin
Saxby designed all those years ago the
concept of a semiconductor company that
outsources manufacturing isn't that
uncommon Nvidia and AMD both do it this
approach reduces costs but it also
reduces your profit margins and makes
you really reliant on your manufacturing
partner that's why Intel chooses to
design and manufacture its chips
in-house but arm actually goes one step
further it doesn't even sell trips into
the marketplace you'll never see an
armed brand on a specific chip like you
would with Nvidia instead it designs
various IPS like instruction set
architectures and microprocessors and
licenses those designs to anyone who
wants to use them arms customers then
take that IP and design it into silicon
arm is like if a group of talented chefs
wrote elaborate recipes and sold them to
restaurants around the world sometimes
the restaurants follow the recipe
sometimes with the permission of the
chefs they tweak it a bit and whenever
someone buys a meal at one of those
restaurants the chefs get a one to two
percent cut arms business model is great
because it creates a positive incentive
loop as arms designs become better so do
the devices their processors are used
for and as those devices sell more R
makes more money in royalties which the
company invests back into r d to make
better designs today arm works with
pretty much everybody Apple Google
Microsoft Qualcomm Samsung tsmc bite
dance you name it and their energy
efficient processors have perfectly
positioned arm to take advantage of
trends like handheld devices wearables
and cloud computing arms Innovative
design and unique business model
attracted lots of attention one of the
people watching closely happened to own
the world's biggest investment fund his
name was masasone and in September of
2016 that investment fund SoftBank
bought arm for 24 billion pounds it was
the most ever paid for a European
technology company and in 2020 the
collaboration between Apple and arm went
to the next level when Tim Cook said
that the Mac was transitioning to Apple
silicon what he really meant was that
Apple was shifting production of the max
CPU from Intel's x86 architecture to a
system on a chip based on arm processors
much like the iOS range of devices it
was a sign that arm is encroaching on
the territory that Intel has held onto
for decades and it's just the latest
step in the fascinating decades-long
symbiosis between arm and apple when you
zoom out the numbers are truly
staggering arm claims that more than 250
billion arm-based chips have been
shipped revenues have never been higher
and with over 1 000 Global Partners
including companies working in emerging
areas like machine learning cloud
computing and even the metaverse those
numbers will probably keep going up arms
CEO Renee Haas has a saying wherever
Computing happens arm will be there
today Computing happens everywhere and
tomorrow Computing will happen in places
we can't even imagine an arm will be
there to learn more about how Apple's
new product The Vision Pro marks the
culmination of Tim Cook's career just
watch this video next thanks a lot